I think when you have a people-based
business if you don't understand how
disproportionate culture is I think
you'll lose and what I mean by losing is
there's unbelievable amounts of
businesses out there that are winning
financially that don't have good culture
it's not good it's anxious it doesn't
need to be toxic it's just not great
it's like a job it's like whatever you
know for me those companies are missing
out on top line revenue and profit I'm
telling all of them get everyone feeling
safe accountable but happy place I call
it honey Empire honey over vinegar but
we're trying to build an Empire
sometimes garyvee head of Vayner X the
advertising holding agency YouTuber you
have a lot of things welcome to decoder
thanks for having me Dakota is a sure
about structure and process and decision
making and you have the most of that so
you just have a lot going on let's start
at the very beginning
how are your companies structured how
does that work vaynerx that you just
mentioned that a lot of people don't
know about you know they they see the
garyvee of it all but they don't realize
that there's been 15 1600 person global
company
vaynerx the main company's vaynermedia
the company I started in 2009 with my
brother AJ that's the advertising agency
that's the Mad Men Madison Avenue thing
we do media and creative together which
is a little bit of an innovation in
today's marketing World which means we
spend the media and make the content
um that probably that has 1200 or so of
the employees
uh New York La
Toronto Mexico City London Amsterdam
um Singapore Australia and a lot of
other uh people in the aipac region
so that's that and then the next biggest
companies in vaynerx are the gallery
Media Group which houses purewow.com and
1 37 p.m so it's publishing similar to
what you mean all of you are doing then
there's the Sasha group named after my
father
um that's a Agency for smbs so we're
getting so much inbound especially given
my career on like more mom and pop
businesses not the Pepsis and the chase
but exactly so we wanted to create
something of that that's been really
fruitful James Rossini runs that there's
Vayner 3 which is an innovation strategy
company AI uh blockchain VR QR uh that's
more like a bain and McKinsey company
Avery runs that that's going well Vayner
speakers a speaking bureau Zach runs
that
um then there's Eva no Saddam which is
Madison Ave spelled backwards even
though Saddam Productions which is a
production company that makes our
commercials we do you know a lot of
Super Bowl a lot of uh different kind of
commercials the Jimmy John's
um uh young gravy ad recently the
Cheetos thing we do Dwayne Wade a couple
years ago when he retired for Budweiser
those kind of things so that's the
production company
so that's kind of like the you know a
big ecosystem uh of ours there's Vayner
Commerce a Commerce business so that's
that world then there's the Moonlighting
I do helping out my dad with the
original business Wine Library talking
to my best friend Brandon uh warnicky so
that's that world it's a Wine Library
wine techs.com that's going super well
especially wine techs get a text today
reply get discounted wine
um there's Vayner Sports my brother AJ
and Greg genske are the co-ceos of that
AJ left halfway through the Vayner
journey and wanted to do something he
loved that's become a very big business
we just announced the basketball
Division with babe Frazier who was
mellow's right hand for all those years
um but we're very big in baseball Boba
Justin Turner many others football Kirk
Cousins Aiden Hutchinson many others UFC
Stephen Milich Corey sandahagan many
others so that's going super well
then there's V friends I've always
wanted to buy a intellectual property so
I used to think I was going to buy The
Flintstones or Gumby or the Smurfs the
nft thing came I'm like wait a minute
this is a place to launch it I launched
me friends a couple years ago so that's
my intellectual property a business
grounded in blockchain but also expanded
to the real world and then there's a
little tiny room these days though it's
been a big chapter over the last decade
of the garyvee of it all right you know
all my content
um I'm really not public speaking
anymore I am writing a new book but it's
taken me a little while with how busy I
am
um and uh and all the content creation
the podcast so that's historically been
a business in itself though when we
friends came up it sucked all the energy
out of the garyvee of it all because
I've got to really run that so that's um
then there's obviously my investing I do
a lot of Angel Investing some through a
fund with Phil Toronto and my brother AJ
uh vaynerfund three
um
and then there's boards I sit on
non-profit and and public and or private
um so yeah busy so you mentioned they
are actually 60 other people that's a
big holding company that's got the Ad
Agency and a bunch of other stuff then
you mentioned some companies that are
not part of it how do you decide what's
in what's up what's in vaynerx what's
not in vain X so the reality is is that
I do I do view you know be friends and
and vaynerak says the two cores but
there are moments when AJ needs me on
Vayner Sports there's going to be
moments as Eric wattenberg builds out
our production company where I'm gonna
have to fly to LA and pitch a show for a
big opportunity on Netflix you know it's
going to happen
um
so I decide based on
two
Chiefs of Staff and three admins
whose full-time job is to take all the
inbound that comes in my text and my
slack and my email and strategize we
spend a lot of time you know during the
week thinking about the three weeks
ahead we're always you know lots of
15-minute meetings instead of 30 trying
to make a lot happen and then you're in
you're it's almost like being in the
news business you know like like all of
you you have your editorial strategy but
then you know it's like in the sports
media business you have your strategy
for today and then Aaron Rodgers gets
traded to Jets officially and that's
going to change up and that's what being
an operator at a high level I think with
multiple things going on is I have my
strategy for this week but anything can
happen in the next hour that blows out
three hours and then those three hours
have to get back in the books because
those are top five percent things in a
world of a million things being thrown
at you and so it's a constant flow how
much do you delegate
right actually in your slack your admins
have like full stock access to to your
scary ends scarier than that my admins
have access to everything yeah my iCloud
my my email
I live a transparent life with my
accents like you know they're they might
they're in sign into all my social
um yeah I keep it very transparent with
them because I need to be able to
navigate quickly and they need all the
data points so I delegate tremendously
yeah I don't think you really can I
would argue that for a lot of people
listening or watching
all of their limitations on the growth
of the things they're operating by the
way whether that's a family that you're
operating and not delegating enough to
the oldest child or to a friend or an
aunt or a grandparent or if you're
running a business or like me many many
many businesses delegation trust the
lack of ego of thinking you do
everything the best is an incredible
thing that I most look at when I'm
trying to help a friend family member or
an investment to figure out why they're
not scaling when you say about
delegation there's the admins then
you've got companies you've got people
running your companies how do you decide
okay these are the people who are going
to be in charge of this company inside
of interacts and this company needs to
be outside of interacts with a different
leadership structure um outside of
interacts has been easy Steve Ross the
owner to dolphins is a business partner
of ours and couldn't own a piece of this
sports agency so we spun that out and
then with Vayner so Vayner Sports and
Vayner water the only things outside of
the company Vayner watt because Eric
needed to be such a significant partner
it needed to sit out of the structure
but most things will go into vaynerx if
they're in that service world the way I
really decide that is pretty simple I
either really know or I really don't
know and let me explain
Avery who runs Vayner three
um or Jeannie who runs Vayner Toronto
they were Executives that were here
three four five years doing great work
that made me confident to send Avery to
APAC or Jeannie to up to Toronto
then there's guessing you know I made a
subjective guess on Gabby who runs latam
in Mexico City I mean a subjective guess
on Daisy who'd been in for a couple
months to take over Amia UK Europe and
then in those scenarios you go in
optimistic you go in focused on trying
to help them and then in a 12 18 24 36
month window you're making a final
decision if you made the right car are
you to Autumn here are the matchups on
Judge and Elon make the number go out
not really I'm really yes they can't go
out of business yeah but I'm a little
you know I'm not publicly
held company I'm not looking to exit so
I you know I'd like them to be fiscally
responsible they can't be completely
aloof but I would argue that what I most
focus on is like if you do not have
the people that work for you and I mean
all of them not your direct reports
incredibly happy with you feeling safe
cold I think when you have a
people-based business if you don't
understand how disproportionate culture
is I think you'll lose I really do and
what I mean by losing is there's
unbelievable amounts of businesses out
there that are winning financially that
don't have good culture it's not good
it's toxic it's not good it's anxious
it's it doesn't need to be toxic or that
serious it's just not great it's like a
job it's like whatever
you know for me those companies are
missing out on top line revenue and
profit and so you know I think for me
I'm telling all of them get everyone
feeling safe because there's so much
fear in the world and get everyone
understanding how unique the marketing
strategies we have are or and be friends
what we're actually up to or whatever
company it is Vayner Sports how well we
are in marketing off the field
get the court messages down and
understand them but most importantly
build a safety happy accountable but
happy place I call it honey Empire honey
over vinegar but we're trying to build
an Empire that's you know this is not
for fun and so those are those are the
metrics and and that is a struggle for
people on the outside right everyone out
here these big buildings is being
trained to win on the p l not on the
culture this is actually my next
question please so we've got a big
holding company you've got lots of
empowered Executives yes we talk a lot
on the show about divisional structures
versus functional structures a lot of
tech companies are functional right Tim
Cook runs marketing and he runs product
and it all rolls up to him and at the
end of the day they somehow produce an
iPhone
other companies are divisional right
you've got just a stack and you've got
some redundant functions and then how is
how is vaynerak structured a little bit
of a mix of the two yeah you know the
reality is I do a lot of casting on
leaders yeah you know the what's
interesting is we're a 13 year old
company
but vaynermedia vaynerx is even younger
that happened when I bought pure wow we
started building it six years ago
a lot of this has to do with you know HQ
the vaynerx of it all has its leaders
but we keep that pretty thin and we give
a lot of power to the leaders of
Divisions and companies
but you are micromanaging and creating
redundancy while you're it's almost like
a kid riding a bike yeah you've got to
give them training wheels especially if
they're from the outside when I bring in
new leaders from the outside I'm going
to create some cushions
you know just because the reality is is
we do it very differently both the craft
and the culture and so once someone is
able to like cross over the hill then I
think we can make it you know far more
autonomy based but we like I like to be
close to uh people that have enormous
amounts of control though I have no
interest in micromanaging them yeah so
I'm in the business of bat phone I'm in
the business of making them feel safe
Sebastian bat phone so there's a crisis
here Nicole Gary even more
no everyone has the same number but it's
it's you know it's funny it's not yes
crisis it's more like just like keep me
close use me you know so many of these
leaders actually ironically we had a
global offset yesterday
um
so many of them want to prove to me they
can do it and I keep telling them hey I
know you can do it the problem is you've
been doing it for 20 years on the
outside there's 7 300 nuances here text
me and ask like I'm not judging you I'm
here to help you I work for you but
outside Executives struggle with that
they don't believe me and it sometimes
takes three to five years for me to
break through of like I'm not kidding
like I'm not you're not gonna get fired
by missing your numbers but you
definitely become vulnerable if people
aren't happy and the quickest way for
people to not be happy is for you to be
scared of me yeah and it which then
trickles down do people use your name to
get what they want I feel like at a
company that's called Vayner X run by
Gary vaynerchuk you mean Executives with
each with each other what's this does
that happen I'm sure I'm sure that's
happening the the cool thing is as a
13-year company we have almost 100
people that have been here for nine
years or longer with crazy retention and
I think what's awesome about that when I
hear this I would say six seven years
ago probably a lot more than today
there's too many people entrenched in
too many places that know the truth of
it all that it's almost like been it's
almost like a double negative like like
there's there's so many family members
in so many different places that I think
it doesn't it's harder to get away with
that but I'm sure that happens every day
yeah I was just curious especially when
your name is on the door what's cool is
I have such an aggressive open door
policy that ironically the junior people
use me more than the senior people at
times and so a lot of people are
comfortable even like a year in only
meeting with me once but based on
everything that they know to email me
and be like hey my boss's boss boss said
this is this true and I'm like no or yes
like you know it's it's I couldn't
encourage leaders that are listening
here more on finding as many five and
ten minute slots to say hello to a new
employee like just that breaking the ice
of it all is massive yeah this brings me
to I think the decoder question you're
describing right this process you have
where you you make big long-term
strategy you have a vision and then
you're very reactive to things that are
happening to you incoming information
all along how do you make decisions so
I'll answer that and I love how you put
that I literally operate on macro
patients and micro speed
I make decisions based on a lot of
things one
um my intuition I really do believe that
I think a lot about what do we know
today that people didn't know 100 years
ago a ton a ton about the body the mind
I always ask myself what are people
going to know 100 years from now that we
don't know today my favorite running
thesis right now is that we don't talk
enough about the gut the intuition the
operating system that this is we know
this is but we don't talk enough about
this and so my big guess in 100 years is
this is understood a lot more and it's
like a normal part of life intuition you
mean that's right microbiome both by the
way okay ironically it's funny I was
about to say that but that's exactly
right both actually how much of an
impact on your life this is so intuition
is very big pattern recognition is
enormous for the 23 year olds harder for
everybody who's 45 and older massive
experience matters these gray hairs
start to add up right they do have value
and so pattern recognition number three
a complete utter focus on intent and
lack of fear every decision I make I
know has good intent truly thus
rendering me very confident that if
there's ramifications or I made a
misstep that the the apology is always
there that the correction is there the
vulnerability the humility I'm not
scared of making a wrong call and I
think that's a huge part of my decisions
and then tons of data the reason I want
the bat phone which is really more just
check in and let's keep talking is I can
make fast decisions when I'm sitting on
a lot of information yeah and so I'm
talking to all my employees all the time
virtually through text or in person
mainly to make me have the ability to go
fast in the future one of my biggest
beliefs is that most CEOs don't spend
enough time judging the judgers
I am judging my 40 50 most senior people
on how much I value their word blindly
like Marcus and Hannah my chief of staff
who I'm looking at across the window
right now because they've been here for
nine and 13 years or less but a road to
it for an executive that's maybe running
a company or an office that's only been
here for two or three years yeah I can't
be blindly with them yet I don't have
enough data but
the framework I work in so I'm just
talking to you uh here in person you're
very animated very Charming you're very
direct I have discovered that when I'm
very direct in digital communication
come off like a huge trick
how do you do all the things you do and
communicate digitally with your team I
don't communicate digitally you know
you're not slacking you're not I I do
but I'm petrified of it I tell everyone
if it's something real get out of text
yeah the misinterpretation of the
written word digitally is a Monster yeah
people will consume it based on their
framework
or when I do it and I have to give any
level of direct I'm coming with a heart
emoji and a sun right behind it I do
that a lot and I do that a lot because
I'm petrified that someone's losing the
tone yeah we had a Cole just joined our
team we just joined our WhatsApp where
my team works on our content he doesn't
know me yeah and if I've got something
to say right he might think on his first
day like wait a minute Gary's actually
full of he's not as nice like I
need to put that heart emoji I think
people need to the voice memo so they
can hear my voice
um I'm petrified to deliver even neutral
to slightly candorous feedback in just
written word I think it's a massive
mistake I have completely gotten my
leadership team off of the long email
that's talking about like today we've
had like I mean I'm like it's crazy
you're scaring people so you know you
know again if it's with Sid who I've
been with for eight or nine years I
could do anything he knows it's cut
meaning he in written form because he
knows it's coming from a good place but
back to your point when I'm being direct
which is by the way Ironically garyvee
in interviews my content great a Candor
Gary vaynerchuk the executive has
struggled historically with Candor yeah
I hate negativity I hate I've always
seen Candor as something that would
scare people I had a misunderstood for
the majority of my career so I call it
kind Candor you need to if you're
delivering Candor you need to be
empathetic that the other person on the
other side is not going to feel great
yeah even if it's like truly Fair
they're still going to feel bad about
themselves so why not have compassion
and try to make them feel a little bit
better by referencing something you've
struggled with or just fixing the tone
so I think about that a lot yeah I
always think about it in terms of you
can tell people it's okay to feel bad
and then you can work through it
together but that first step is really
hard yeah or you could really put it on
yourself as a leader and try to make
them feel less bad yeah like there's
absolutely a way to make someone feel
slightly less bad when you're telling
them that they're not good at their job
let me talk about carrying me with you
you brought up this other character
garyvee versus Gary vaynerchuk the
executive yep the business of garyvee
yes seems as complicated as chaotic as
anything and it exists on social
platforms forever changing yes we were
talking to your team just before you sat
down about just how much video of you is
logged every single day yes and what an
enormous operation is is guarantee
that's a character you're playing no no
oh it's it's me fully
um it's just the context of the room is
different right now I know that we have
a long form video an audio execution and
I do believe that being slightly
entertained or engaged and this was
something I did subconsciously when I
first started speaking I didn't it just
I have intuitive understanding that
you're more likely to get your message
across that people actually pay
attention
right so no I don't there's nothing that
I've ever put out on the internet that
is stick or fake yeah um it's just that
the context is different if I'm having a
company off site that's trying to
navigate a 350 million dollar a year
business you can imagine with 15 people
that's going to be a very different tone
and tenor yesterday than me doing a
podcast on one of one of my favorite
media platforms out there like I'm just
gonna be more excited I know that
somebody's running on the treadmill
right now walking their dog driving in
their car and I want them to continue to
hear the words and if it's like super
serious and mundane that might not be
the energy you're looking for I'm also
aware that my energy might be too much
for someone this is like too hyper and
that's okay this is just what naturally
happens to me when there's cameras going
and so no it's not character life it's
just a slightly more animated version of
myself given that I get more excited
when I think there's more people
involved but when you have this many
people following around with cameras
vlogging everything you say ingesting it
into what sounds like a very impressive
air table system I'm very jealousy
you're a reality show right I mean like
you're kind of producing a daily reality
show and that naturally has to heighten
whatever loudest characteristics you
have I don't know about that I'll
explain if you look I would argue that
YouTube is the platform that I do least
well yeah mainly because I'm not overly
passionate from a reality TV show
standpoint meaning I'm not trying to
rate I don't want the Vlog to be overly
successful from like winning an Emmy or
getting a lot of viewers I'd be fine
with it I'm trying to document way more
than I'm trying to entertain yeah
um a big part of the Vlog was done
because I lost both my grandfathers
before I got to know them and I thought
it would be neat that one day in 67
years this would exist I also knew that
it would bring awareness and demand but
I really wanted it as a blueprint for
people to see like this entrepreneur
thing is not so fun like it's not as
easy as it's not cool as it's become and
so
yeah no I don't you know there's for
example
there's nothing that I do day to day
that has anything to do with the Vlog
yeah it's just a documenting framework
well I can ask you do you ever turn it
off yeah right a lot what's quiet
vaynerchuk like the weekends the the the
holidays you're out there like flipping
Beanie Babies man very you know I think
what I've done really well is back to
them following me around is I've garage
sailed three times in the last three
years yeah I'm just very good at content
creation of maximizing what I do so no I
mean on the weekends I'm spending time
with my family uh I'm decompressing
um quiet me is still hyped like I'm an
excitement you know like I'm excited I'm
happy I'm I'm incredibly motivated and
grateful for having a life I think that
people take for granted I uh I'm on the
board of uh charity water yeah 850
million people on Earth more than 10
don't have access to clean water
I find it very hard to not be excited
about life when we live in a first world
country where both my parents are alive
where I have great siblings and a family
like I'm very fortunate and so gratitude
is a huge like I think people have envy
and jealousy and dwelling and
complaining DNA and that's a drainer but
when you're grateful and optimistic
you're kind of just excited for like
like I'm pumped when a weekend is this
sunny I actually noticed today when I
was working out that it was really sunny
and then my brain said I hope this
weekend's going to be nice yeah like I'm
grateful for very simple which
makes me excited and calm
when you think about the image you put
out into the Universe I watch your tick
tocks I love your tick tocks you're
always talking to an audience yes right
it always seems like you're addressing
some room yes that's the majority of
your content your audience does not see
that you're just walking on the
treadmill and you're happy that it's not
outside with your family you have a very
particular kind of image do you worry
that you're leading people to believe
that you're always on and that they
should themselves always be on no I
don't worry about that at all I think
for example I think people find what
they're looking for like yeah like I've
been very aggressive of like I don't
want to share my personal life I have
tons of challenges I speak about
vulnerabilities I am a public figure
people know about my stuff like no I
really don't I understand the question
yeah I think that it's time that we have
a more thoughtful conversation around
this meaning I as a human when I consume
content at scale never believe that any
of the people that I'm consuming are
showing you every single thing of their
life nor do I believe it's as good or as
bad or is it I I think that's a very um
lazy intellectual point of view and so
you have that money because you grew up
with it I grew up with the internet I
grew up with well YouTubers right but go
ahead grew up with you right it didn't
exist and it slowly has gotten to where
it is now and you've seen that whole
transition I think about our young
audience
they're fishing they don't know about
the water right they just grew up in a
world where influencers exist in a world
where YouTubers exist where being a
YouTube star is a career path that you
can tell your parents when you're five
years old right and so you have this
view where like this isn't all real then
you're making the reality show oh that's
what makes me reality show and you have
an audience that doesn't know
that it's a show well I I think you I
think the way you frame that up is a
little awkward let me explain I think
everything I show is real it's just not
the complete part of my life and there's
certain things I decide not to share
yeah you know I think I also think when
I think about this when I was a kid
pre-internet
we we looked up to stuff too you know my
big question is where is parenting in
2023 yeah like like I I think that but
you are that figure for a lot of for a
lot of people young men in particular
you are that figure yeah but I you know
that is such an extraordinarily deep
challenge right like you know when I
think of being someone that someone may
look up to I'm humbled by that and so
much of the way I create content
understands that to be true but I could
never comprehend you know the the
complexity of actually being someone's
parent or you know someone loses a
parent and who who replicates or fills
that void you look at that kind of from
a human journey and there's many inputs
that fill that void yeah I think that's
right I do think that there's incredible
um Intrigue that I have about the sheer
volume of people that are putting out
information in the world
but I feel like that has always been the
game like there's an entire generation
of Boomers who live their life like
Mickey Mantle because he was the one
that they looked up to so it's always
existed what I'm actually optimistic
about is there's way more ways to look
at things today and I think how people
choose their paths is interesting you
talked a lot about being adaptable and
that experience there's a tension there
right uh you in particular are very good
at using your experience to adapt to new
Platforms in particular from YouTube to
Instagram to tick tock to nfts if that
pans out yep how do you think about that
tension all right we gotta we're doing
well on YouTube but I got to take
everything I know and go find a new
audience on Tick Tock because you talk
this is something you talk about a lot
like a lot you gotta jump when the
time's right you gotta jump when the
time's right if that's your ambition you
know back to your point which I thought
was really great in the last series of
questions one of the things I talk a lot
about back to people hearing what they
want to hear is you need to be
self-aware over everything and
understand the journey you're on so if
you're a business and you want to grow
your business
you have to go where the consumer
attention is that's just the requirement
so the way I think about it is I am on
my journey to try to build as much
awareness as possible for the things
that I'm passionate about that requires
me to I'm not thrilled if tomorrow black
jacket becomes a hot platform but I have
no choice but to take it seriously
because this is you know for me I enjoy
my craft I enjoy my job and I want to do
that on the flip side I'm very
empathetic and talk a lot to the
audience of like hey you this happened
huge three four years ago I'm like tick
tock tick tock tick tock tick tock tick
tock and everyone's like dude I'm just
getting Instagram down and I'm like cool
you're more than welcome to not do it
you have to understand the attention is
going to move there and you need to
understand where you are on your journey
you can't be ideological about where you
want the consumer attention is you need
to be where the consumer attention is
yeah I guess the reason I ask you that
is that constant change that platform
churn I'm looking at this state of
social media today I'm looking at a
bunch of YouTubers who are worried about
growing out culture and they talk about
it openly I'm worried about a bunch of
tick talkers who seem like they rose
with the platform got burned out and
they've kind of receded yeah right that
first wave of really big tick tockers
they kind of pulled back but that's good
isn't it I wonder I it feels like being
the most famous person on YouTube is no
longer a great business
it was never a great business being the
most famous person I mean think about
what we're dealing with you and I grew
up in an era where we knew that child
stars
it was tough yeah and so a lot of these
kids get so much Fame and money at such
a young age it's really hard
to calibrate that so you're coming at
this from like a marketing perspective
that when you talk about attention right
what I hear is okay this is a great
marketer who's saying okay I gotta go
send a message and we gotta move to the
platform and be native platform there is
a generation of entrepreneurs who are
like this is my business my business is
making content you know a bunch of
things of course of course uh and you go
between those worlds right garyvee is a
brand that makes content as a business
I'm sure it's monetized if you're the
world's best tick tocker
and you reach the peak you're not making
as much money as if you turn around and
launch a merch line and stop making tick
tocks and that pattern to me since
really it seems like the we're at the
end of the road like everyone's realized
the centralized social platforms are not
stable foundations to build businesses
meaning if you're just monetizing as an
influencer yeah if you're Montana even
if if they're your core marketing
platform well that would be like saying
running commercials on Seinfeld is not
sustainable no yeah like once it's
not got the attention you have to move
on yeah so like as core marketing I
think it's crazy to not extract
awareness from where it's actually being
consumed yeah so that's that to your
point on the human element that's a
whole different game that comes down to
Parenting and DNA right right like when
I met the demilios I was like oh these
girls are extremely fortunate this is
like a real dad and mom yeah it's like
my Vayner Sports business
you know do you know many athletes grow
up with nothing and then sign big
contracts and the ones that have
self-awareness and stability do
incredibly well with their money and
their life and the ones that don't
become quite vulnerable to your point
when you're a business it's easier to
move ebb and flow when you're a human
there's going to be a natural time where
you can't deal with the negative
comments the workload but I view that
more like the way we looked at like the
Madonnas and Michael Jackson's and all
those people in the 80s which is I think
you'll see them ebb and flow it was
funny I was listening to a Bruno Mars
song this morning and like it was just
in rotation on my Alexa and I was like
where is Bruno Mars like he right now
and I was thinking I'm like oh he's
probably like chilling right now and
like decompressing from world tour and
all that Fame we've seen every single
famous person over the last 40 50 years
it's impossible to stay white hot
forever because you're a human and you
need to take a break I mean I did five
years of a wine show every day from 2006
to 2011 and was like really out and
about and going and then in 2011 from
2011 to 14 I made very little content
building the foundation of this business
a because this business was an
opportunity but B because I was like I
don't want to make wine content every
day my daily Vlog I did it every day for
three four years filmed everything the
team will tell you right now with their
head nods we've been getting back into
it I don't want to film half the stuff
because I'm out of because I'm because
I'm out of rotation yeah I'm like in
this place that I think every human
should be comfortable when they want to
go for it when they don't similar to
working out yeah I'm sure in your 42 you
said yeah you've had moments where
you've been better or worse about eating
and exercise habits I think the same
thing for an influencer like they're
gonna be hot at certain times they're
not going to be hot and what I mean by
that is they themselves they're going to
be intuitive times they're not going to
be into it at times and I think the the
influencer business yeah I think is
incredibly sustainable I just don't
think it's sustainable for every person
every minute and to your point some of
them have other entrepreneurial
capabilities so that seems like the path
out right it seems like once you've once
you find your way out to Prime right or
whatever yeah but how many people are
going to be able to be Emma Chamberlain
Logan Paul and you know and Mr Beast
yeah right like there's a lot of brands
that have been started by a lot of
people like you know when I did empathy
wines years ago as a DTC brand I knew
that I could do it because I was an
operator a lot of these people are not
actual operators or won't find a partner
operator that's good and so I I think
that it's a and conversation not an or I
think there'll be plenty of people that
will continue to be a personal brand in
perpetuity just like there are
celebrities who get paid to be
celebrities in perpetuity to your point
some of those celebrities Jessica Alba
some of those celebrities Reese
Witherspoon Ashton Kutcher had DNA Ryan
Reynolds Kevin Hart The Rock so I think
it's going to be and for some people but
I do think the long tail of influencer
is a sustainable business model but to
your point I don't think every human nor
most humans can do it forever they'll
have been flow and ebb and flow yeah do
you think that it's harder because the
platform has changed so much I think
it's easier you think it's easier too
what did we do grabbing and flowing in
in one of your middle of your down
period everyone's attention moves from
YouTube to what if you're short what
about when you add them flow as John
Travolta and then people decided they
didn't want to give you a chance again
he was out of the game for 15 years but
I mean his business was selling acting
Services right if you're an influencer
and you're making branded Integrations
with your YouTube videos and something
that market disappears because all the
attention's on Tick Tock but it's core
of your business but but you know you're
speaking to a world that I don't think
exists yeah no I think it's great let's
talk about it in the last what are we in
2023 in the last 17 years
how many of the biggest platforms have
disappeared off the face of the Earth
Vine which was only nine months old yeah
right dear sweet one I know so when a
lot of these people came from that that
really actually if you look at Vine I
think Vine will be historically looked
at very interestingly because it's what
started short form video at that level
but if you really look at the last 17
years
YouTube Facebook Twitter right Instagram
Snapchat Tick Tock it's not like they've
disappeared one of them seems like it
might be disappearing in front of our
eyes Tick Tock Twitter
might be a whole other thing well I
think you know I've been you know
Twitter if I'm reading the tea leaves
and I have no inside info or any
curiosity but if you look at this whole
X and like like it looks like what Elon
is signaling is he wants to build an app
that's more similar to WeChat in China
which is full stack I'm really curious
what that all means but I don't think
it's going away it seems like it's about
to be potentially part of something
bigger yeah but it seems like the users
are like thinking about what what's next
right
like so they're the business either way
it's we you're correct we've rarely seen
platforms disappear I think we have seen
them lose relevance right and in
particular I think that mid-form YouTube
video the Vlog is like it used to be the
gold standard it's whatever it wanted to
build and now everyone wants to build
tick tocks and stuff so I think look
it's so funny you say that because I
actually have a slightly different take
it's been crazy to me how many people
are fired up that they're going from
Tick Tock to YouTube shorts and using
YouTube shorts to get 2 million
subscribers to their longer form YouTube
literally my conversation with the tick
tock emerging influencer is their
excitement to go long form on YouTube
because YouTube shorts has given them
the subscribers they've always wanted
because so many of them actually wanted
to be YouTube stars but it was easier to
grow on Tick Tock so I think look it's
different for every person to the last
10 minutes of this combo but I don't you
know I think the old media landscape was
much harder to navigate because you had
be chosen by humans subjectively and now
with these platforms they're empty pipes
and you as a human decide if you want to
enter if you want to be good at it if
you don't ebb and flow in and out and I
think that um I think that's good as
long as the human is self-aware and
doing the right things by themselves how
do you bring this all to your to your
clients again what's the Advantix yeah
this company is fair media it's the Ad
Agency yes a lot of the clients now the
internet is not a foreign concept
when you started it was right yes this
is a very new pitch theme yes but now
there are other great ad agencies that
are native to the space what's your
pitch how do you go and make business
debut is that where the
word we think they're also too bullish
on tomorrow you know even though I was
very bullish and continue to be on nfts
the macro we had clients who wanted to
build million dollar metaverses last
year and I was like are you out of your
mind there's like four people in the
metaverse so they gave excited about
tomorrow they're way too religious about
yesterday and our pitch is like we're
the best of today we do the media buying
and the creative the strategy behind
that creative for the 10 platforms
LinkedIn Facebook Twitter Instagram
Snapchat Tick Tock Pinterest
and when we get the consumer insights
out of that creative the quantum qual
data the numbers and the comments it
allows us to have a better brief I'm
pointing to that because usually it's
about that long of a brief to then make
the longer form videos that are modern
day commercials we want to make the
commercials that are going to be strong
on Hulu connected TV fast channels and
so that's our pitch we're an ad agency
that just thinks that television ads are
overpriced and bad digital is overpriced
and you should do today's best and
social happens to be that now but if I
started vaynermedia in 1997 it would
have been email and and then in 2000 we
would have gone into search and in 2041
we may be completely out of social
because maybe the attention is on VR or
metaverse I'm very agnostic I'm not
overly passionate where the attention is
uh back to the tick tock thing Gary what
happens if tick tock's banned I'm like
we'll go where the like I have no
emotion towards Twitter or Tick Tock or
Facebook or Instagram what I do have a
motion to what you mentioned earlier is
as long as I'm acting in my professional
life I understand that attention matters
I'd like to understand where the best
price is to get that attention and I'd
like to be good at bringing value with
the videos words and content because I
know that that always will work for the
business if they're providing value let
me ask you one question about attention
and I want to end with nfts yeah you
talk about attention like a commodity
like you can price it and sell it yes
it's pretty ruthless actually like in a
just a business sense you're talking
about like you're trading oil or gold or
something yeah
I am a news person that takes my
attention a very different way yes I
watched one of your Tech talks the other
day you were telling people how to make
great content you know if you got a
thought just Google it find an article
green screen yourself in a full article
this is how you can capture attention on
Tick Tock and I thought one that's
brilliant I told our team to start doing
that with articles and then two I
thought this is scary should I ever
heard because now we're trading on other
people's trust trust that there's a news
article but we're just doing it to
harvest attention well that's when that
ruthless side of it where we're just
harvesting tension I feel like there's a
danger there well I think that's what
the news does like I think humans are
just acting like to your point most of
the news that I consume on Fox decoder
CNN and any other place that's good you
got me up there I got you brother listen
I think Jim you know just full
disclosure I don't know if I should
disclose it's like
um like I admire Jimmy's Journey on
building this Media company so yes I'm
so pumped for all the stuff you're doing
the very so much good stuff
um but that's what it does right like
like when Adam some schefter reports
something CBS says Adam schefter report
you know like I actually think what
humans are doing with green screen which
was a creative strategy of the moment do
you feel like you have a responsibility
to use the attention you harness
positively constructively because if
you're pretty ruthless there there are
other people who don't feel that way
right who are just after it for traffic
who are just after it for clicks or just
after I agree for attention yeah and
you're right on the precipice where you
talk about it like a commodity but I
know you and I know you feel that
responsibility what is that
responsibility for you I want to be
historically correct I want to feel good
when I put my head on the pillow I want
to talk about the things I'm passionate
about yeah I don't I don't need to make
my money uh you know I don't monetize
that attention directly the way media
does I monetize that from awareness if
people are interested in the things that
I do and then there's secondary
realities of like here's a book or
people come and see me speak thus
rendering my speaking fee high or I make
a wine and I'm like hey I think this is
a better 20 wine and that attention
gives me the opportunity to ask for an
opportunity so no I I do think attention
is the most important commodity in the
world I don't think of it like I bought
it for a dollar and sold it for a Dollar
too I think of it as like when you have
your children before they're 18 that
attention is everything in the framing
of how they're going to live their life
and you better take advantage of the
attention when you're a business person
if you can get attention you get a
chance to tell people about your
products and services it doesn't mean
they're going to buy it I actually think
one of the biggest issues of people who
go patient with attention is they expect
people to buy stuff from them after
they've done a good job by getting the
attention in a good way and I always
tell them you're not entitled to them
buying anything you're entitled to
getting a chance for them to know about
it so that's how I think about it go
sign with your friends a few friends is
maybe the ultimate example of you have a
lot of attention on yourself yes and you
sold out products to Consumers yes in a
way that apart from the wine I don't
think you've sold a lot of correct those
are the two moves
the sneakers a little bit books a little
bit and I hear you on you want you've
always wanted to have IPS if you found a
technological opening to create a
franchise
nfcs were pretty weird in that moment
right they were pretty bubbly they were
people were buying them way too high yes
the market has crashed yes do you have
any regrets about that whole situation
not really
um because I mean micro regret you know
like like I I made a ton of videos of 99
of these nfts are going to zero yeah and
I mean a ton of that at the height so
that's why I'm able to answer not really
because I was talking about it in a very
macro way the other thing was it was
important for me to make my nfts be a
part of something that was physical so
befriend series one came with three
tickets to a super business conference
called vcon that the price of the mint
was worth the conference in itself yeah
so and then series two came with trading
cards that have created a lot of Demand
on eBay and things of that nature so I
feel macro good of course there's a
million things you want to do a little
bit better of getting over excited
during moments along the way but I'm
really glad back to like do I feel a
response ability on making content yeah
I but in you know in when be friends
came out one in May of 21
it was a very young Market it kind of
and then things went bananas right so in
August and September and October of that
year I started changing my content to
hey this is something you need to learn
about to hey 99 of these are going to
zero like to your point where nfts are
on the macro pricing not the technology
the products that the the Beanie Babies
of it all not stuffed animals are going
to be here for 100 years the beanie
babies and the Garbage Pail Kids have
been all right people come up to me like
what do you what I'm like look like this
was always about the macro technology
and there was unlimited content of 99
are going to zero but people will hear
what they want during that time when I
was like because they're paying you
money for a thing right well but but
that was long you have to said they paid
money for a thing in May right which
again came with physical items and the
nft was that's a reframing right so now
the value is the physical items the
value wasn't a reframing if you go watch
all the like it really wasn't it was
there's a collectible I will spend 50
years trying to build this IP let's see
what happens if I'm capable yeah comma
here is the conference that comes with
it and this is how it's priced so you
know the good news is like one great
thing about documenting everything and
doing this all the time is it's there
yeah it's there I also have the benefit
of like genuinely believing that I'm
gonna make people fall in love with
optimistic otter and patient Panda and
that becomes a Marvel and Pokemon
Journey over the next two decades and
this goes you know you really touched on
something so important for me what's the
person's intent
you know you said do you have a
responsibility in your content yes
that's why I put out what I put out
um do I have a responsibility to make
this a big thing we sure do a lot of
people want to believe that I'm going to
be able to pull it off and I believe I'm
going to be able to pull it off so I
think the intent and then the actions
because you can't just have intent is
gonna become what everyone is judged on
and I take that stuff serious what do
you think the timeline uh for the
friends and then to use your word Macro
for nfts to become serious to become
meaningful
well I mean series one is Meaningful now
it's dramatically above even with an 80
90 decline massively above what people
paid for it
um
but to your point
and twelve eight you know I think a lot
about years yeah
um it's just going to take time like to
get millions of people to care about you
know rare robot and you know I've gotta
I'm you know I started a TV production
company to do animation I signed a kids
book deal you know we've done toys
already with Macy's and Toys R Us like
it's just a lot of work right it takes
time
um
you know but you know I think what's
cool about nfts is when you bring
utility in the smart contract that was
always what gave me peace of mind to
your point empathy selling wine peace of
mind when you're selling 40 wine for 20
bucks people are gonna like it
we friends what gave me peace of mind
was the collectible cards the access and
then the super conference and then the
access that comes along the way like
different mini events for an island all
these you know working on it every day
so
um you know meaningful comes in a lot of
different ways for a far majority of the
audience it's already been Roi
meaningful and now the collectible sits
there as a added value for others to
your point that maybe bought it at
higher prices when all the hype I still
got a lot of work for them probably to
be fulfilled because they didn't buy at
the mint price yeah and so you know
that's something I need to work on
forever I guess I'm meaningful in the
sense that it's an nft but nfcs are the
technology that enabled you to introduce
the IP you mean the macro nft got it
right but the idea that we're out there
buying and selling nft Collectibles is
not a mainstream idea right it was a
very bubbly idea but it's far from the
mainstream when you think it goes
mainstream 10 to 12. I think that's yeah
I think because because they're going to
be about utilities it's more like you
know one of the analogies I used all the
time was
ticket steps yeah yeah like you go on
eBay right now you will it's hit the
ground
every fish concert every sporting event
like just unlimited ticket stops
similar with nfts I think all tickets to
Madison Square Garden over there in a
decade are going to be nfts and then if
the LeBron of that day Victor the kid
that's coming from France if he drops
100 points in that game well that
becomes a collective like to me nothing
changes
the way people collect like the reason I
thought 99 would go to zero is because
99 of sports cards are zero 99 of comic
books are zero the one percent yeah get
real interesting Jordan rookie
Spider-Man number one
um so I think 10 years I think VR you
know what's interesting AI
is gonna speed up a lot of the web 3
movement because I think it you know
right now back to like uh using other
people's IP green screen I think that's
more of like a media function of the way
reporting works but I think what's
happening with AI creative and
information what's the source and a lot
of big companies are starting to think
about litigation to these AI companies
but I think the blockchain proving
Providence of source has a you know I've
been fully you know I'm in the lab I'm
thinking about this I don't like saying
out loud because I don't know if I'm
right or wrong but I tend to like to
talk when I fully know but there's
something that feels right there it'll
be interesting how it works yeah we are
doing us way more time than anticipated
thank you so much thanks for having me
talk soon
[Music]